[Musique]
Je suis tellement triste pour tous ceux qui ont perdu
leurs propriétés que nous venions
de louer ici, Dieu merci et nous avons perdu
toutes nos affaires mais nous nous en sommes sortis, c'est
ouais, je suis tellement triste pour tous ceux
qui ont vécu  ici depuis si longtemps
et ils ont toutes leurs affaires ici, nous avons
été appelés pour un incendie dans la
zone plate de Busby et nos enquêtes ont
révélé qu'il s'était passé quelque chose de
suspect dans cette zone,
la cause de l'incendie est toujours  en cours de
détermination, mais nous avons identifié
une activité suspecte dans cette zone, donc
c'est pour une enquête en cours
[Musique]
vous